country's next biggest star gabby
barrett is getting some very valuable
advice from the one and only
dolly parton in celebration of gabby's i
will always love you
amazon original cover the 20 year olds
had the chance to interview her biggest
idol and this was actually
gabby's first time meeting dolly and i
think it's safe to say this was probably
the highlight of her career so far hi
[Music]
gabby
oh my gosh i am walking on the clouds
right now
i mean she's just the cutest now the
american idol alum
is coming up on her one-year wedding
anniversary to fellow idol alum
kade boehner and she's also expecting a
baby girl
so dolly took the opportunity to give
her some valuable
relationship advice my husband and i
always had a great
friendship and we're both funny we both
have a great and warped
sense of humor so we've always had a
good time
and he's pretty much a loner in a
homebody and i'm a gypsy but when i'm
home i love that
we don't do the same thing so it gives
us stuff different to talk about
he doesn't get involved in my business i
don't get involved in his so we have our
own
little world that we create for
ourselves
i mean if there's anyone who knows a
thing or two about making a marriage
last
it's definitely dolly parton she's been
married to carl dean for
54 years okay so here it is the country
legend advises to
take time apart from your significant
other in order to stay happy
which might be the reason why she and
carl have never
fought i know we've never bickered back
and forth because i never wanted us to
say bad things that we would have to
remember
we get a little you know pissy now and
then but we'll just kind of
walk off or go do something else and you
know kind of let that die down
and so we just we just kind of you know
have to work at anything
marriage is a is a business too and you
kind of gotta
look at it like that you gotta make the
right decisions
for all the little things that come up
okay so here's another tip
dolly told the i hope singer that the
first year of marriage is
probably the hardest you are trying to
like say figure each other out and
learn things that's the year that you
probably get
you know the most rubbed wrong
only because you're having to share your
space with somebody you've never had to
share your space with before
your habits are different than theirs
and so you got to work those little
things out and it's best just to go to
the other room
rather than getting in a big old
argument about it cool off and don't
know
they're just as entitled to their
opinion and their space as you are yours
so if you can think of it like that and
just to you know when you
both feel like you can you know kind of
calm down and talk about it
then that's where the love's supposed to
come in
and as it turns out dolly is a huge fan
of gabby
and assures her of all the success
that's coming her way
i mean can you just imagine dolly
telling you that
your voice is great by the way i just
think you're amazing as a lot of people
do
i really wish you a great and long
career and i think you're gonna have it
there's no doubt about that because
gabby recently made history with her
album gold's mind
earning the most first week debut album
streams for any country act in history
of course the album also features
gabby's first ever number one song
i
on
hope